drastisches reformkonzept für
deutschlands elite soldaten die
verteidigungsministerin löst nach
rechtsextremistischen vorfällen teile
des ksk auf höherer mindestlohn ab
januar dann sollen niemand mehr weniger
als neun euro 50 pro stunde verdienen
später sollen es dann zehn euro 45 sein
und aus auf schalke der heftig
umstrittene aufsichtsratschef tönnies
legt beim fußball bundesligisten sein
amt nieder
nach 26 jahren
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers einen guten abend in
allen herzlich willkommen bei uns um 7
sport nachher in der sendung mit katja
stresow wenn die
bundesverteidigungsministerium den
soldaten ihre eigenen elitetruppe sagt
sie müssten sich entscheiden ob sie teil
der lösung oder weiter teil des problems
sein wollen dann ist das ein
paukenschlag und damit beginnen wir
heute abend
annegret kramp-karrenbauer will die
eliteeinheit der bundeswehr zum teil
auflösen
das ksk das kommando spezialkräfte kann
nicht in seiner jetzigen form bestehen
bleiben steht in einem
untersuchungsbericht des
verteidigungsministeriums grund sind
eine ganze reihe von
rechtsextremistischen vorfällen dort
cornelia schiemenz hat die details
bislang fühlten sie sich unantastbar das
ist aus und vorbei
das ksk die elitetruppe der bundeswehr
wird grundlegend und strukturell
verändert weil das eigenleben
übermächtig wurde rechtsextreme fälle
sich häuften weil negativschlagzeilen
überhand nahmen es werden auch von
vorneherein keine maßnahmen
ausgeschlossen
im abschlussbericht der ministerin das
bittere fazit dass sich das ksk
zumindest in teilbereichen über die
letzten jahre verselbstständigt hat
abgeleitet aus einem ungesunden elite
verständnis einzelner führungskräfte
daraus folgt dass das ksk nicht in
seiner jetzigen verfassung bestehen
bleiben kann
das kommando spezialkräfte darf keine
blase innerhalb der bundeswehr bleiben
sondern es muss ein reger austausch
stattfinden ansonsten besteht immer die
gefahr dass wenn man in schlechte
gesellschaft kommt man auch ein
schlechter gesellschaft verbleibt die
kompanie die 2017 mit einer sogenannten
schweinekopf party und hitler grüßen
negativ aufgefallen war wird komplett
aufgelöst die ausbildung der
ksk-soldaten wird ins heer integriert
internationale kooperationen werden
eingestellt
die maßnahmen im blick auf das ksk sind
alle richtig auch mit bezug zu dem
zeitraum was eine kontrolle der
maßnahmen anbelangt aber
nichtsdestotrotz ich will nicht
ausschließen dass wir nicht irgendwann
im kommenden jahr wieder einen
einzelfall haben das kann keine
ausschließen auch nicht mit blick auf
die gesamte bundeswehr
das ksk ist nun auf bewährung bis
oktober sollten sich die zustände da
nicht ändern steht eine völlige
auflösung weiter im raum
eine elitetruppe auf bewährung das muss
man sich mal auf der zunge zergehen
lassen
theo guten abend wir reden von denen die
eigentlich deutschlands besten soldaten
sein sollten
was ist da schief gelaufen in all den
jahren ich glaube da muss ich gar nicht
irgendwelche abstrusen action filme
vorstellen offensichtlich hat sich in
dieser elite truppe wirklich ein
ungesundes selbstverständnis
ausgebildetes urteil der arbeitsgruppe
zur ksk es jedenfalls verheerend
neben dem liter verständnis und einer
verselbstständigung der truppe hätten
sich auch extremistische tendenzen
entwickelt und laxer umgang mit munition
und material bei einem sächsischen ksk
man hat man ja erst kürzlich ein
waffenversteck ausgehoben und insgesamt
fehlen offensichtlich 85 tausend schuss
munition und 62 kilogramm sprengstoff
und das ganze wurde dann auch noch muss
man sagen von einem falsch verstandenen
chorgeist lange gedeckt und wie soll es
jetzt weitergehen in der zukunft und
wird das ohne murren hin der truppe
funktionieren können also das würde mich
sehr überraschend wir hören aus dem
verteidigungsministerium dass man im ksk
schon ordentlich geschluckt hat
angesichts der sehr weitgehenden
strukturellen veränderung forderungen
der ministerin diese elite einheit hat
offensichtlich seit ihrer gründung
praktisch ein eigenleben geführt dass
jetzt aufzulösen dürfte schwierig werden
insbesondere angesichts der besonderen
arbeitsumstände dieser kampftruppe aber
frau kramp karrenbauer hat die hürde
jetzt sehr hoch gelegt und wird daran
gemessen werden insofern dürfte die
spezialeinheit nicht auf politische
milde hoffen
danke für diese analyse heute abend theo
koll zdf berlin so und jetzt in der
sendung eine entscheidung auf die viele
mit spannung warten es geht um den
mindestlohn die frage heute wie hoch
soll wie hoch darf der mindestlohn
künftig sein
das ist nicht ganz einfach in zeiten von
corona aktuell liegt die feste
untergrenze für löhne bei 9 eur 35 pro
stunde für eine kräftige erhöhung
spricht dass die pandemie arbeitnehmern
einiges abverlangt sagen die
gewerkschaften
gegen ein starkes lohnplus führen die
unternehmen den einbruch der wirtschaft
an
heute jetzt die empfehlung der
mindestlohn soll in vier stufen auf 10
eur 45 steigen florian hahn
in der krise waren sie plötzlich
systemrelevant hätten arbeiter wie sie
nicht einen höheren mindestlohn verdient
oder wäre ein anstieg gift für
unternehmen und jobs stunden lang
verhandelte darüber heute die
mindestlohn kommission aus arbeitgebern
und gewerkschaftern am ende eine
einigung die sozialpartner haben heute
wieder mal bewiesen dass auch in
schwierigen zeiten
gewerkschaft und arbeitgeber gut
zusammenarbeiten können einstimmig
beschlossen ein anstieg in vier
schritten anfangen 2021 auf 9 eur 50
schließlich im juli 2022 auf 10 eur 45
weit weniger als von den gewerkschaften
gefordert trotzdem öffentliches lob wir
gehen davon aus dass es etwas ist das
sich sehen lassen kann
vor allem auch im hinblick darauf dass
wir einen deutlichen schritt gemacht
haben in die zweistelligkeit dass der
anstieg zunächst so gering ausfällt hat
einen schlichten grund stehen
wirtschaftlichen einbruch der gar noch
schlimmer ausfallen könnte der deutsche
industrie und handelskammertag rechnet
heute mit minus 10 prozent deutlich mehr
als von den sogenannten
wirtschaftsweisen erwartet letztere
hatten zudem einen schnellen
wiedereinstieg vorhergesagt in form
eines v wir befürchten dass es jetzt
stark runter gegangen ist also der erste
teil des faust ist erfüllt und dass er
sich jetzt in ein wandel tvo bei der
zweite teil des nicht wieder steil nach
oben geht
dessen ungeachtet will der
arbeitsminister den mindestlohn
beschluss nun umsetzen
doch in werthers heil macht auch
deutlich 2023 wünscht er sich einen
deutlich höheren mindestlohn 12 euro
werden in diesem zusammenhang als
richtmarke genannt ich finde das eine
gute orientierung als etappenziel die
mindestlohn einigung von heute kleine
etappenziele in schwieriger
wirtschaftlicher lage
und noch eine entscheidung heute um die
es lange streit gab die union gibt jetzt
grünes licht für die grundrente die im
alter denen helfen soll die wenig
verdient haben und deshalb auch nur
wenig rente bekommen das ist ein
herzensprojekt der spd das jetzt in
dieser woche noch im bundesrat tag
beschlossen werden soll
zugfahren in deutschland soll
attraktiver werden bundesregierung und
bahn nennen das masterplan
schienenverkehr
bis 2030 soll es doppelt so viele
bahnfahrer geben wie heute und mehr
güter auf der schiene der bahn anteil am
gesamten güterverkehr soll steigen von
jetzt 19 auf dann 25 prozent
und dann geht es um den sogenannten
deutschlandpakt schnellzüge auf
hauptstrecken jede halbe stunde schritte
in die richtige richtung sagt die
opposition aber es gibt auch zweifel am
zeitplan und an der umsetzung
und jetzt das thema corona seit zwei
wochen gibt es in deutschland die korona
waren es 14 millionen menschen nutzen
sie inzwischen nach zdf informationen
haben bisher etwa 100 infizierte ihren
positiven test gemeldet und dadurch
andere menschen mit denen sie kontakt
hatten gewarnt
die zahl der neuinfektionen geht aktuell
weiter zurück im durchschnitt der
vergangenen woche haben sich täglich 470
menschen mit dem virus angesteckt
bayerns ministerpräsident müller sieht
sein land als vorreiter bei der
bekämpfung der korona pandemie bayerns
regierung beschloss heute kostenlose
freiwillige tests für alle jeder könne
jederzeit und auch wiederholt beim arzt
einen corona test machen lassen sagt
söder
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
hatte das vorhaben kritisiert und von
einem trügerischen sicherheitsgefühl
gewarnt patricia schäfer berichtet was
markus söder heute verkündete gibt es
bisher in keinem anderen bundesland
bayern bietet corona tests für alle an
kostenlos und mit schnellem ergebnis
wenn die krankenkasse nicht zahlt
übernimmt die kosten der freistaat man
kann nicht nur immer erleichtern
man muss einen gegenzug ein angebot
machen das testen
übrigens ist testen ein frühwarnsystem
testen ist auch vorbeugung ab morgen
kann sich jeder einwohner bayerns beim
hausarzt testen lassen auch ohne
symptome und mehr als einmal
für euch die großeltern besucher oder
irgendwelche leute die vielleicht zur
risikogruppe gehören würde es auf jeden
fall machen aus dem urlaub kommen ja
wenn ich im eigenen land bin finde es
wirklich überflüssig
schon jetzt wird getestet wer zu
gefährdeten berufsgruppen gehört oder
symptome hat um das neue test konzept zu
bewältigen sollen zukünftig statt 20.000
30.000 tests pro tag möglich sein
ich denke dass dieses ungezielte testen
von personen die jetzt meinen zum
zeitpunkt iks wissen zu wollen wie sie
vom infektionsstatus sind nicht wirklich
ziel bringen ist die korona tests für
alle sollen sicherheit vermitteln aber
wann sind sie wirklich sinnvoll
im kindergarten in der schule wenn man
gefährdungen hat aber nicht ihm
letztlich ausschließen kann dass enge
kontakte stattfinden und wenn man den
alten menschen besuchen will ist es
durchaus sinnvoll am tag vorher oder am
gleichen tag einen test zu machen
das lässt sich bayern viel kosten 200
millionen euro stellt der freistaat pro
jahr zur verfügung für sein neuestes
konzept
die europäische union hat heute
beschlossen hat menschen aus einigen
ländern wieder nach europa einreisen
dürfen
in der zdf- heute- app finden sie eine
liste dieser 15 länder von algerien bis
2 dort erklären wir auch warum die usa
nicht dabei sind wichtige entscheidung
heute des bundesgerichtshofs es geht um
das basiskonto auf so ein konto hat
jeder in deutschland ein anrecht auch
wenn er wenig oder gar nichts verdient
denn ohne konto ist es zum beispiel fast
unmöglich eine wohnung zu finden
die deutsche bank hatte allerdings geld
für ihr basiskonto verlangt pro monat
acht euro 99 für einzelne leistungen
kamen dann noch mal einen euro fünfzig
dazu zu viel urteilten die richter in
karlsruhe
der eigentliche sinn des basis kontos
würde so unterlaufen
eine gebührenobergrenze legte der bgh
aber nicht fest und jetzt in der sendung
ins ausland und zu einem gesetz bei dem
schon der name für streit sorgt gesetz
zum schutz der nationalen sicherheit in
hongkong oder kurz sicherheitsgesetz
nennt es die regierung in peking für die
demokratiebewegung ist
im gegenteil ein gesetz als
unterdrückung als werkzeug der
unterdrückung
trotz internationaler proteste das
umstrittene gesetz wurde heute
verabschiedet und ist auch schon in
kraft aus peking ulf röller eigentlich
werden bisher in hongkong keine
demonstration genehmigt offiziell aus
angst vor krone aber nicht jede
demonstration ist gleich völlig
ungestört feiern die anhänger pekings
das nationale sicherheitsgesetz so der
offizielle titel
es scheint hongkongs autonomie weiter
ein dass finden sie gut
das sicherheitsgesetz bestrafe die
demokratiebewegung die die hongkonger
aufstacheln würde für unabhängigkeit zu
kämpfen wie heute morgen verabschiedete
das chinesische parlament einstimmig das
nationale sicherheitsgesetz wer gegen
peking auf die straße geht kann jetzt
schnell zum putschisten werden und muss
mit hohen strafen rechnen
nur vorsichtig wagten sich einige
hongkonger bürger gegen das neue gesetz
auf die straße
denn jede kritik gegen peking ist
gefährlich niemand weiß genau was in die
gesetz drin steht und welches verhalten
wie hart bestraft wird
eigentlich hatte china bei der
emotionalen übergabefeier hongkongs die
autonomie der stadt bis 2047 garantiert
aber nach den massenprotesten im letzten
jahr ließen pekings machthaber hart
durchgreifen präsident skis strategie es
selbstbewusst der westen lege sich mit
china nicht an denn er sei von chinas
wirtschaft zu abhängig und hongkong sei
zu unwichtig sie glaubt dass sich die
kräfteverhältnisse in der welt zu seinen
gunsten ändern
china bringt hongkong auf linie und
zeigt der welt so seine stärke
der vorwurf klingt unglaublich russland
soll den taliban kopf geld gezahlt haben
wenn sie ausländische soldaten in
afghanistan um bringen
mehrere us zeitungen hatten darüber
berichtet und sich auf
geheimdienstinformationen berufen
in den usa dreht sich jetzt alles um
eine frage was hat der präsident davon
gewusst
aus washington in das trans gab es
todesopfer unter amerikanischen soldaten
die auf kopfgelder zurückzuführen sind
die russland auf sie ausgesetzt hatte
der russische geheimdienst soll taliban
in afghanistan angestiftet haben
amerikanische und britische soldaten zu
töten
spätestens im märz soll präsident trump
diese information in seiner täglichen
briefing mappe erhalten haben
trump hält dagegen seine geheimdienste
hätten diese informationen nicht für
glaubwürdig befunden
man hätte sie ihm nicht gegeben seine
sprecherin ergänzt die geheimdienste
haben sich widersprochen es gab keinen
konsens dem präsidenten aber werden
solche informationen erst vorgelegt wenn
sie bestätigt sind wusste trump nicht
oder hat er nichts unternommen um seine
soldaten zu schützen welche rolle spielt
trance nähe zum russischen präsidenten
putin fragen die demokraten im kongress
heute wurden sie vom weißen haus
unterrichtet ich kann trumps von putin
nicht nachvollziehen
es gab kopfgelder ausgesetzt auf
amerikanische truppen wenn einen das
nicht sofort ab drehen lässt dann weiß
ich nicht was das militär auch die
familien von gefallenen soldaten werden
klarheit fordern was wusste was
unternahm der präsident wir alle der
präsident aber auch die ganze nation
schulden diesen großartigen amerikanern
und unseren partnern die da draußen im
einsatz sind unsere unterstützung bei
dieser unterstützung darf es keine
unklarheit geben sollte trump sich vor
putin stadt vor seine soldaten gestellt
haben könnte das auch den wahlkampf
beeinflussen
wir sollten heute auch auf die
verheerende lage in syrien gucken auf
die menschen dort die seit neun jahren
unter dem krieg leiden
eine geberkonferenz hat heute fast
sieben milliarden euro hilfsgelder
zusammengebracht fast 1,6 milliarden
davon aus deutschland
damit sollen hilfsorganisationen den
menschen besser helfen können
auf der flucht haben 5,6 millionen
menschen das land verlassen die meisten
sind jetzt in flüchtlingslagern in der
und in syrien selbst sind fast zwölf
millionen menschen auf hilfe angewiesen
an seinem stern berichtet dem tod im
bürgerkrieg sind sie entkommen bis jetzt
und doch kämpfen sie ums überleben jeden
tag der krieg die virus krise für so
viele in syrien heißt das es gibt nichts
mehr zu essen
die preise gestiegen um 200 prozent in
nur einem jahr den märkten können sie
viele grundnahrungsmittel einfach nicht
mehr kaufen weil die preise viel zu hoch
sind sagt amin er ist lehrer in der
stadt homs und arbeitslos wie es
weitergeht für seine töchter weiß er
nicht denn das geld das syrische pfund
verliert immer weiter dramatisch an wert
die lebensmittelpreise sind so hoch wie
nie
im neun jahren krieg die leute sagen uns
dass sie sich das essen nicht mehr
leisten können
sie müssen warten bis die preise fallen
stellen sie sich das vor
sie warten nicht darauf einen fernseher
oder sportschuhe zu kaufen
sie warten auf lebensmittel dringend
brauchen die hilfsorganisationen also
das geld der internationalen
geberkonferenz experten schätzen dass in
syrien mittlerweile weit mehr als neun
millionen menschen hunger leiden und das
neun jahre nach dem beginn der blutigen
kämpfe
hunderttausende sind tot millionen auf
der flucht und in lagern die
leidensgeschichte der syrischen
bevölkerung sie nimmt kein ende jetzt
versuchen wir hatten schnitt in der
sendung und mache mit sport weiter und
mit einigem was mit sport allerdings
dann doch nur am rande zu tun hat katja
wohl wahr turbulente zeiten in
gelsenkirchen clemens tönnies ist heute
von seinem amt als aufsichtsratschef
beim fußball bundesligisten schalke 04
zurückgetreten tennis stand zuletzt
häufig in der kritik und das nicht erst
nach den über 1500 corona vorfällen in
seinem fleisch betrieb der
traditionsreiche fc schalke 04 sucht
einen neuen chef
nach 19 jahren an der spitze des
aufsichtsrats tritt der unternehmer
clemens tönnies ab zu viel war in dieser
saison zusammen gekommen die sportliche
teil
16 sieglose spiele in der rückrunde die
teilnahme am europacup zum dritten mal
in serie verpasst auch deshalb die
andauernde finanzielle misere mit fast
200 millionen euro verbindlichkeiten
stand vor der korona pandemie nordrhein
westfalen soll mit einer 40 millionen
euro schweren ausfall bürgschaft helfen
plus die rassismus-vorwürfe gegen
tönnies nach seinen umstrittenen afrika
aussagen und immer massivere fanproteste
der präsident geht schalkes probleme
bleiben jetzt zum rollenden fußball
überstunden müssen übermorgen werder
bremen und der fc heidenheim im ersten
relegationsspiel leisten die bremer
kämpfen quasi um ihre existenz und
heidenheim möchte zitat die lebens
chance auf den aufstieg nutzen
trainer frank schmidt konnte sich nicht
gleich über den relegationsplatz freuen
die niederlage in bielefeld und die
schwache auswärtsbilanz der heidenheimer
insgesamt machen nicht gerade mut wir
brauchen in bremen so ein ergebnis das
uns hoffen lässt im rückspiel an die ja
schon sensationen auch zu glauben der
nach 13 jahren als trainer in heidenheim
dienstälteste coach im deutschen
profifußball steht mit seinem team
trotzdem vor der chance des lebens
manche dinge im leben bekommt man gar
nicht oder nur ganz wenige male und wir
haben jetzt diesen diese situation dass
wir was machen dürfen was
außergewöhnlich ist am donnerstag das
hinspiel in bremen das rückspiel in
heidenheim am montag danach
und sie glaubt man das unglaubliche
glaube versetzt berge
ja ja ja dann kann eigentlich nicht mehr
viel schiefgehen vielen dank an ja es
wird nass morgen erwarten uns heftige
gewitter und viel regen mehr dazu gleich
von besten terry 21 uhr 45 ist zeit für
claus kleber und das heute-journal und
morgen freuen wir uns wieder auf sie
aber erstmal in allen einen angenehmen
abend tschüss
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter der regen im
westen deutschlands der dehnt sich über
nacht weiter aus in den osten und auch
morgen tagsüber gibt es gewitter ja und
dieses regengebiet das schwenkt dann bis
zum abend in den süden aus ja und in der
nacht regnet es im nordwesten teils
schon ergiebig im süden da ist es eher
trocken und stern klar und dort
temperaturen bis 11 grad am alpenrand
und 17 grad zum beispiel am niederrhein
morgen am vormittag zahlreiche schauer
und gewitter im westen schon mal ja und
im süden da scheint häufig die sonne zum
nachmittag wird es dann unwetterartig
teils mit platzregen sturmböen und auch
hagel gut möglich und diese gewitter die
den sich weiter in den osten aus im
süden dann zum späten abend dann auch
hier vom bergland dann ausgehend heftige
gewitter temperaturen dazu bis 31 grad
im südwesten 29 im rhein main gebiet und
20 am kühlsten an der nordsee am
donnerstag im süden deutschlands
weiterhin heftiger regen teils mit
gewittern durchsetzt bis 26 grad und die
darauf folgenden tage weitere schauer
aber nicht mehr so heftig ein schöner
abend